on c-span 2 the pendulum is a mere axles
new biography of 19th century french
scientist léon foucault this public
lives feature is about 50 minutes input
tonight's speaker Amir DXL
Excel he is a leading science writer and
made his reputation with books such as
Fermat's Last Theorem entanglement and
riddle of the compass and he's here
tonight to have to discuss his latest
book pendulum léon foucault and the
triumph of science and I'd like to have
you join join like to have you join me
in welcoming to Olsen's Amir Axelle
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here tonight at all since my book
pendulum léon foucault and a triumph of
science is about the greatest problem in
scientific history and that's the
problem of the rotation of the earth so
I want to ask you a question suppose
you're sitting in a train and you look
out the window and you see movement the
other train next to you is moving or is
it you who is moving is it your train or
the next train and usually it may be
approach the window and then see that
you are really moving or but maybe it's
the other train but suppose on the other
hand that you fell asleep on the train
and you open your eyes and you see all
the trees coming toward you at the same
speed all the trees and there's a farm
house and a factory and they all come
toward you with exactly the same speed
what would you think well obviously I
think anybody with some intelligence
would say of course I'm moving and not
everything else now it seems a little
silly in terms of a question but that's
really how scientists and scholars and
average people treated the problem of
the rotation of the earth and of
relative movement throughout early
history when you look out at
night and you see the stars all the
stars are moving if you're watching them
for several hours at the same speed all
the stars the moon the Sun during the
day they're all going across the sky at
the same speed now the logical thing to
think is well I'm the one who's moving
and not all the stars moving at exactly
the same speed but apparently people
didn't like that they couldn't handle
the fact that if everybody's moving at
the same speed that it's much more
logical to assume that you're the one
who's moving like the Train with with
the trees and people actually died for
believing that the earth rotated so if
you professed that it was the earth that
rotated rather than the entire firmament
of the heaven the Inquisition would burn
your life as they did with Giordano
Bruno in a year 1600 in the centre of
Rome he said that the earth rotated and
the Inquisition burned him Galileo
almost had the same faith for really
purpose supporting the Copernican view
that the Earth rotates rather than
everything going rather than the Sun
going around the earth and in 1633 just
33 years after Giordano Bruno was born
by the way there are many others who
were burned at the stake by the
Inquisition there's some in France and
in other parts of Europe I'm researching
a book about Descartes now and I came
across several other people who were
burnt in France for saying that the
earth goes around Galileo being a very
smart man at this trial as we all know
the story was shown the instruments of
torture and he said okay the earth
doesn't rotate now there was a church
official who was instrumental in both
the trial of Galileo and the trial of
Giordano Bruno if you can call these
trials and that person by name of
Barberini wrote a letter to another
church official the name of foscarinis
saying if somehow we could have actual
proof of the
of the earth we will stop doing it we
will accept that the Earth rotates but
you haven't produced a single piece of
evidence you meaning scientists and
people who were who kept their eyes open
and and and really tried to understand
nature if you could give us a piece of
proof for that then we will we will
accept it now what the church really did
not want to believe that the earth
rotates because of the Bible in the
Bible it says the Sun rises and sets now
today with a little bit of logic we read
that it's easier to say I watched a
sunset rather than say I saw the earth
rotate enough for the Sun disappear
behind the horizon but the church really
stuck to these biblical statements as
being true and anybody who said that
they weren't and it's actually we are
rotating suffered very much the problem
excuse me is not only of the church the
problem was that some of the Greek
philosophers and mathematicians who
observed nature said that it's the earth
that rotates while others said that it
didn't others said that everything else
goes around the earth and Aristotle was
one of the most famous Greek
philosophers who said that the Sun is
really going around the earth and the
stars and the planets and we're really
the center of all creation and that view
became entrenched now people started
looking for terrestrial proofs of the
rotation of the earth in order to
finally give truth that will satisfy the
church and the common people as well and
they looked at various thing the cart
himself obviously one of the greatest
philosophers in history
realized that if you fire a cannon in
the northern hemisphere in the direction
north the cannonball would deviate to
the east and opposite in the southern
hemisphere the reason it's called the
force of Coriolis and I can actually
demonstrate it to you in terms of a
merry-go-round on a merry-go-round
if you stand far in the
periphery and you move inward you will
be pushed to the side that's called the
force of Coriolis and the reason that
was discovered by a French mathematician
by name of Coriolis the reason for that
is if you have a surface that's rotating
it makes a bigger circle when you're
further out so you have actual speed
that's larger than the point point
that's closer in and if you're at the
very center you're just rotating with no
actual speed so when you move yourself
from the outer part of the SIRT of this
moving surface rotating surface inward
you carry with you the speed that you
head outside and that's what tilts you
pushes you to the right that's what
would push a cannonball the earth being
round in the northern hemisphere and
then you fire it north to in the
direction north you're getting it closer
to the North Pole which doesn't move but
only sits there as the Earth rotates and
therefore the Cannonball would deviate
to the east so now it makes a lot of
sense to us that would be a proof of the
rotation of the earth the cart wanted to
find that proof and he told a friend of
his by name of Mersenne in the letter if
you fire cannon in a certain way you
will discover the rotation of the earth
but the friend misunderstood him and
took another accomplice of his who was a
an army military base in France they
obtained a cannon and they fired it
straight up into the sky there are two
versions as to what happened next one
version says that the cannonball
disappeared but the other one is more
interesting it says that they actually
fired three cannonballs instead of
firing in the direction north they fired
straight up that one cannonball fell 500
feet to the west the second one 500 feet
to the east and when they fired the
third one one of them said oh no but the
law of averages the next when we follow
in our heads and they took off from
there so people did all kinds of things
trying to find this proof that would
satisfy the church and and everybody who
was not an astronomer or a scientist and
to give the final proof of the rotation
of the earth people threw stones down
mine shafts to see if they deviated
East and from tall buildings and all
kinds of things but nothing worked now
the trial of Galileo was in 1633 and it
took two hundred and seventeen years
from that and Galileo was a great
scientist he came very very close to
giving a proof of the rotation of the
earth because Galileo you see discovered
the law of the pendulum he did that as a
very young man and he discovered that
the pendulum I have just a small one
here
I'm not trying to hypnotize you over the
small pendulum a small oscillation and
the large one take the same roughly the
same time this is called the love the
isochronism
of the pendulum and Galileo discovered
it but he and he discovered it by
sitting in church and in the wind during
a windy day and watching the chandelier
swing and up above and timing it against
his pulse and he realized this law of
the pendulum but didn't study the
pendulum long enough to realize that if
you somehow could let the pendulum swing
in any direction it wanted with no
torque here on this line it would shift
its direction of swing slowly as a
response to the rotation of the earth
and if you think of the law of core of
the force of Coriolis it will become
apparent to you what happens here now
what so what I'm trying to show you is
the irony that Galileo who was so
persecuted by the Inquisition came so
close to to really getting at the final
proof which had to wait another two
hundred and seventeen years from 1633
the year of his trial to six to 1850
1850s the modern age already most
scientists in Europe believed that the
earth rotated and many educated people
did but the proof still was lacking one
day on January 6 1850 a man by name of
léon foucault set in the basement of his
house he lived with his mother never
married and
houses in the best part of Paris very
fashionable area then and today
Americans when they do go to Paris like
to live in that area tanned the send
young man part of Paris and a very
fashionable street and down below he was
playing with a pendulum making it swing
from the ceiling and he watched it and
on January 6 1850 at 2 o'clock in the
morning he wrote in his notebook 2 a.m.
the pendulum changed the swing in the
direction of the celestial sphere and so
who was Foucault Foucault was an
untrained scientist he was a reporter
for the French Academy of Sciences the
French Academy of Sciences is a very
haughty body it's members called
themselves called each other and still
do today share confer savant which means
dear scholarly colleague when you go in
there as I did to research the book to
the building which was built in the
1600s
everything is lined with red carpets and
they're statues of famous mathematicians
and you really feel like you can open
your mouth in there or move and and
everybody looks at you like you don't
belong there and that's what happened to
Foucault he was a reporter and he
reported in the newspaper about the
month about the weekly meeting of the
French Academy of Sciences and here was
this reporter who was untrained in
science and who had all these great
mathematicians and physicists of France
treated as a lowly person finally he
found the final truth of the rotation of
the earth now how would he tell it to
the world
well Coe had a good friend in the
observatory of Paris and he thought that
this man was less arrogant than the rest
of them and might be willing to help him
and in fact this man by never far ago
who made one of the measurements
important measurements of the meridian
of paris allowed Foucault to demonstrate
this pendulum in the observe
veturi so he got a much larger pendulum
and hung it from the top of this place
called a root called meridian hall in
the paris observatory and then he did
something interesting he wrote little
notes and he wrote on them come see the
earth turn tomorrow at five o'clock in
the Paris Observatory and he sent it to
all the mathematicians who never really
wanted to say hello to him or nod to him
now I should say something about these
mathematicians and physicists two very
well-known names are Poisson and Cauchy
who are dead by that time and that
they're very well known mathematicians
anybody who said in mathematics knows
about the Cauchy sequence and the
Poisson process and they were the
pillars of French mathematics both of
them said about 15 years earlier one of
them actually in 1837 so fourteen
thirteen years earlier in one of the
proceedings of the Academy that if you
observed obviously people were looking
for proofs of the rotation of the earth
if you tried to observe a pendulum and
see if it will tell you that the earth
is rotating you will not find it the mo
the movement of the pendulum is not
significant enough to be observed if it
exists at all so this was in writing in
a particular journal and all the
scientists of the Academy therefore
never thought of a pendulum because
they're great once said that it wouldn't
work but Foucault who was untrained and
uncorrupted by conventional wisdom went
they hadn't tried it so then in the
second trial in the second experiment he
sent this invitation to all these people
who believed that the pendulum would not
do anything and they came and they
watched it and they called it in French
a bell experienced a beautiful
experiment but right away they said oh
we could have told you that we knew that
anyway and there wasn't the last of the
problems that Foucault faced so the
mathematicians immediately took to their
equations and said to each other these
are people who lived with equations and
and and and derivations and could derive
the laws of nature on
and they said well let's derive the loft
nature that allows the pendulum to do
that and hukou was a step ahead of them
before they had the formula to explain
what was going on he already had the law
that told him how a pendulum would shift
not only in Paris were you observed it
but anywhere on planet earth and fucose
law is a relatively simple formula it
says that the time it takes a pendulum
to complete a full rotation from from
its beginning plane of oscillation all
the way around and back is equal to 24
hours divided by the sine of the
latitude the latitude of where you are
now to explain that I have a tiny globe
here if you're standing at the north
pole or the South Pole for that matter
and you can see the earth is rotating
sort of under the pendulum which is why
you observe the rotation of the earth
using a pendulum because it's hung up
there and it has no torque so it can
swing in any direction it wants so to
speak so here you have the earth and let
me see if I can do this here is your
pendulum and this as the Earth rotates
the pendulum sticks to its direction and
it's an illusion that it changes its the
earth that's rotating unless you want to
view it as a Coriolis effect you could
see it that way as well but it's much
easier to visualize it as what's really
happening the earth is rotating and your
pendulums stays at the same direction
now what does a pendulum follow there's
something called machs principle that
came some years later that says that
fucose pendulum follows all the masses
in the universe which i think is
something very mystical here's a
pendulum it ignores our planet the
planet is rotating right under it and
the pendulum the pendulum keeps its
direction of swing with respect to all
the distant stars in the universe so it
maintains its direction while we're
rotating right under it so we know that
Earth rotates at the rate of twenty
four-hours-a-day
so
full rotation is 24 hours and therefore
the pendulum will complete it's changing
its direction coming back to where it
started to the plane of oscillation it
starts plane of swing it started with in
24 hours but that's only true at the
poles the north pole or the South Pole
and can't hold it with the South Pole
but above the North Pole this is what
happens now what happens in the equator
and the equator the rotation of the
earth is this way and therefore the
pendulum will not change its plane of
Swing can you see that this rotates the
planet rotates orthogonal this way and
therefore a pendulum in the equator
sticks to its direction and does not
shift its apparent direction is in terms
of what we see now in Paris it took 32
hours so Foucault had one point is 32
hours and based on that he derived this
universal law that says anywhere you are
on the planet the time it takes the
pendulum when it starts swinging to come
back to where it started is 24 hours
which is where would be at the pole
divided by sine the trigonometric sine
function of the latitude where you are
this was a bomb show the mathematicians
when they were given that by Foucault
they couldn't take it anymore
first he proved to us at the Earth
rotates using a pendulum which our great
one said is not possible and now you're
not a mathematician at all you're
completely untrained he was a med school
dropout by the way at very good hands
which we'll get to in a minute and his
mother thought he'd make a great surgeon
so she sent it to med school in Paris
and the first sight of blood he had to
give up and he dropped out of med school
so he was not trained at all uneducated
at the University and still he could and
he is not too he was notorious for
having no mathematical ability at all
and here he gave us fuko's law which
tells you exactly how the pendulum works
anywhere on earth without really
visiting other locations and having like
a statistical data set to to compare
with
so the mathematicians and physicists
were very humiliated and this is you
can't exaggerate it how humiliated they
felt I went through the proceedings of
the French Academy of Sciences and the
mathematicians went to all kinds of
lengths to try to to downplay fuko's
great achievements one of them even
wrote an article saying that when prasun
wrote in 1837 that the pendulum will not
cannot be used to show the rotation of
the earth he is certain formulas and he
made the little error the cosine he used
here should have been a sign and
therefore it had he not been careless he
would have come up with this conclusion
that Foucault had now and all kinds of
things they they did and then come up
with other proofs trying to show that
well it's it was their turf he was not a
mathematician and Foucault was not
accepted still by the club and he was
very upset and angry he he worked hard
on this and the thing about Foucault was
that he was a great engineer so even
though he was not trained as a child
already built a steam engine and a
telegraph machine and he built lighting
for stage which was the best lighting it
was used in the Opera the prophet in
Paris which was shown in in the eighteen
hundreds that was his invention he
invented the gyroscope a year later also
as a secondary proof of the rotation of
the earth and still the academic
establishment didn't want to hear
anything about him at all so Foucault
was kind of stuck he had the greatest
proof of the rotation of the earth
something that we've been waiting for
since ancient Greek times and yet nobody
would give him anything not even
membership in the Academy of Sciences
which was his life's dream so now I get
in the book into a little bit of French
history and Louis Napoleon who later
became Napoleon the third was also an
unappreciated
man who believed that he should be the
Emperor of France he was the nephew of
Napoleon the first Napoleon and was also
a science enthusiast untrained he was he
had several coup d'etats attempts
against the French state trying to
regain control from the king and he was
put in jail and in jail if taught
himself physics and when he escaped from
jail went to England and came back then
became president of France in one of the
most interesting political events in
history where somebody who was Allah
kept him away from France as a as a
relative of Napoleon and and as a part
of the terms of the end of the
Napoleonic Wars was that his relatives
could not come back to France was
arrested trying to take over control in
France twice banished to Britain came
back and was managed to get elected to
the president of to the presidency of
France and then he found out about this
unappreciated genius who proved the
rotation of the earth who had nowhere to
go and he said aha I'm going to give him
the Pantheon which is the greatest that
was built as a church a traitor's
building in in the left bank of Paris
very high it's 67 meters high which is
about 200 feet and he gave it to
Foucault said why don't you do your
experiment here and show the entire
world how the Earth rotates demonstrate
the rotation of the earth with this
great building here the Pantheon is used
as a shrine to the greatest citizens of
France it's a secular building but had a
history of being a church and a secular
building and famous French people's such
as Marie Curie and many others are
buried there Andre Malraux and Victor
Hugo and many others so there was
Foucault he started working right away
and he built a pendulum
there was about a thousand times bigger
than this one it's 30 it was it is it
still exists it's 38 kilograms
it weighs 38 kilograms which is about 60
pounds it's about this size with made of
beautiful brass now the pendulum had to
be made perfectly any imperfection in it
could lead the pen I'm sorry the bob of
the pendulum had to be made perfectly
otherwise the pendulum might be seen to
sway in one direction or another because
of an imperfection and it's weight
distribution and he enlisted the help of
a man by name of ferment who could build
this perfect pendulum and it's a very
beautiful piece made of brass and lead
inside it and it can be seen in a museum
called the CONOPS ena and for its
acronym in paris and he made this line a
steel wire of about 200 feet he hung it
from the top
and all of paris was invited not only
the servants of the academy but all of
paris and barons and baroness azande and
president and conceives me a member of
the assembly everybody came to watch it
took 19 seconds for the pendulum to
complete one swing so you can see it's a
very long swing back and forth and it
was in wet sand so that you could see
how it was making ellipses in the sand
as it was rotating now overnight
Foucault became a celebrity and other
experiments began all over the world
there was two tests fuko's law about the
latitude assignment the sine law with
the latitude it was tested in Brazil
witches in the southern hemisphere in
Rio de Janeiro in New York in England
several places in Holland in one year it
was tested everywhere including in the
Vatican in Rome and the church accepted
finally accepted that the Earth rotates
Pope John Paul's apology to Galileo in
1992 owes everything to fuko's
demonstration in the pantheon their
books written in a Vatican that
basically say that fuko's demonstration
in the pantheon in 1850 finally
convinced the church that the earth
rotates but you guess that the Academy
of Sciences didn't
right they didn't want Foucault to be a
member even if the whole world said he
was a great physicist and here again
Louis Napoleon Bonaparte who a year
later became Napoleon the third when he
finally took control of France by force
he was the president but he wanted to be
an absolute monarch so he had a coup
d'etat and he became the Emperor
Napoleon the third the second would have
been opponents son who died at a young
age so he called himself Napoleon the
third and he said to the Academy
you had better accept this man as a
member and with pressure from Louie
Napoleon and of course the politics that
were involved Foucault became a member
of the Academy in 1865 15 years after
the great demonstration of the rotation
of the earth the final demonstration
that demonstration that nobody could
argue with there wasn't an astronomical
observation which there are many of but
a real proof that the Earth rotates of
15 years later the Academy of Sciences
reluctantly accepted Foucault two years
later unfortunately he died he had the
degenerative illness something like Lou
Gehrig's disease and he well he made
inventions to his last day he invented
incredible new telescopes one at least
of which is used today in the
observatory of Marseille they use one of
fuko's telescopes today in modern
astronomy he really had golden hands he
could do anything he wanted and as he
was getting more and more sick he
couldn't move and he he was an amateur
astronomer building telescopes he was
interested in astronomy it was also he
also became a physicist attached to the
observatory in Paris so that he finally
had an official job rather than just a
reporter which was a part-time job a
reporter in the sessions of the Academy
of Sciences and when he couldn't move
anymore he invented something called a
cider estate which is a way to reflect
the night sky on the wall and his mother
put a couch room in the balcony so he
could still lie there and watch the wall
with his in
vention which you you can still see in
museums a reflection of the night sky
with all the stars on his walls he could
still do his observations even though he
was incapacitated and in 1867 he died
his works were republished by his mother
and with the financial support of
Napoleon the third at the time we
actually had a lot of financial troubles
as the Second Empire collapsed and that
was what his his reign was called as
Napoleon the third was the Second Empire
the first Empire being Napoleonic and
Napoleonic Empire there there were
tremendous difficulties financial
difficulties and he couldn't support
anything but he still gave enough money
to publish fucose works so this is
pretty much my story Foucault and if you
have any questions I'd like to try to
answer them
surely you have some question
that's a mystery
nobody knows he he is notorious he was
notorious for not having any
mathematical ability at all
never could handle a formula or an
equation and yet the need to do it was
stronger than his alleged inadequacy
there is a story that gives us a hint
about it
Foucault had the little wooden balls not
unlike this one and he used to walk
around the Luxembourg garden in Paris
which is one of the most beautiful
places in the French capital and do
little put little dots and and measure
angles on his little globe and one day
he ran into a mathematician and told him
could you yes me protect he asked him a
particular question about his about a
particular angle that he was studying
and the mathematician said on the grass
and pulled out some paper and wrote for
15 minutes and finally gave him an the
answer and Foucault said I thought so
and walked away
he had an intuition a lot of science
real science starts with an intuition
the way a mathematician was you know
we're talking about mathematicians here
all these scientists were really
mathematicians the physicists and
mathematicians were really one in the
same in France at that time or anywhere
in Europe the way these mathematicians
the way they derive their equations
always starts with an intuition so as
you may know I've written a book called
from Mars Last Theorem and from Mars
theorem came out of an intuition he
happened to have been right over ma
wrote another theorem which happened to
be false so sometimes our intuition
tends to be wrong sometimes it's right
but so you really have an intuition
about something then you need to test it
so Foucault probably had an intuition
and he also didn't believe what was
believed by everybody that it you can't
prove it with with the pendulum and he
said well let's suppose that is false
and you can't try it and he tried with
the pendulum and they worked and he
knew what to look for which is why
Galileo couldn't do it and many others
before him people who'd studied the
pendulum they never allowed the pendulum
this degree of freedom because if I
swung this it will stay in this
direction all the time because I'm
holding it and it really needs to be
able to rotate if I rotate it now
they'll be torque on this line and
therefore it will swing back so Foucault
managed to build the it was an engineer
at heart and he managed to build the the
right apparatus that would allow the
pendulum to swing in any direction that
it wanted without hampering it in any
way now I should mention something about
these pendulums that you see in museums
of science and places like that
fuko's pendulums which were he first
worked with would swing until the energy
dissipated and it would stop but by that
time you could see some of the rotation
and it started again and that's how they
knew how long it would take to go round
they'd start again where it stopped and
started again Foucault is such a genius
always a step ahead of everybody he knew
that he should come up with a pendulum
that would spring continually and he
since he worked with motors and things
like they like that arrived a little
electromagnet that would kick this line
when when the pendulum was wood was at a
certain point and he experimented with
that again his intuition told him one
thing and then experience told him how
to adjust that he noticed that if the
the push to the pendulum was when it was
swinging down it would become chaotic
and swing out of any plane and therefore
what he did is he applied the push that
only is it when it was going and in a
certain direction so that it would not
when it was going up so it would stop it
and not not build up and the motor that
he built was used in the Universal
Exposition in Paris which took place in
right just before he died and there was
a perpetual motion pendulum and all the
ones you see today are such they're
given energy so they'll keep forever so
to speak to the swing yes interesting to
me when you said that the mathematicians
at the time sort of looked askance on
what he was doing do you think if
something like that went on today
mathematicians would react to say
I think yes and why I'll give you an
example as to why I believe that first
of all I know mathematicians well
because I've written a lot about
mathematicians and mathematicians tend
to be territorial they like to study a
problem and believe they know everything
about it although they tend to be
cooperative as well but well while Sue
proved from Mars Last Theorem worked
alone in his attic for seven years and
never shared any of his information with
anybody had asked people about results
the room that he needed but he would
never let on as to what he was doing but
there is a good example as to why
Foucault was able to do something and
and and the others not a Swiss
astronomer by the name of Michelle Mayer
discovered the first extrasolar planet
and all the estrade all but many
astronomers said that the particular
star would not have a planet because
they tested it already but Michelle may
your knew that well he was he was an
older guy and he didn't have to compete
for an observation at night of
observation at a famous Observatory such
as the Keck or the Hubble he was content
of a two meter telescope in the South of
France summer when nobody disturbed him
and he also had this way of ignoring
conventional wisdom and ignoring what
the scientists the method well in this
case astronomers were saying he looked
at the star with people told him there
probably isn't a planet and that's why
he looked there he thought maybe not
maybe it's there and he discovered the
first extrasolar planet now we know
there are about 100 of them how do
people react to that my my belief is
that people who believe a certain way
such as the astronomers in this case or
mathematicians in other situations tend
to hold on to their beliefs people are
people they don't have to be
mathematicians or physicists look at the
church the church didn't want to let go
of its beliefs that what we're talking
about here is really giving up what you
want to hold on to as a belief when
you're given new information who would
have believed that their extrasolar plan
until Michelle my yarn July 4th of 1995
discovered the first extrasolar planet
now we say oh sure the lots of planets
out there so that's the same thing with
the proof of the rotation of the earth
and with formulas such as fuko's sine
law I believe that mathematicians
astronomers physicists don't always like
to change their their views or accept
somebody else's good results when they
think it's their territory I hope I
answered your question I don't have any
more hard data than then this
circumstantial anecdotal answer yes you
had a question here Galileo was
persecuted by the church and then was
persecuted by the
and so I was asking where does this need
to persecute somebody who is different
or threatens your position come from and
at the same time where does the drive in
a Galilei or Foucault come from and and
and how can we nurture that more in our
society because our society seems more
and more moving towards conform confirm
making people conform and how much you
what sort making things homogeneous and
everything that's like so how do we
nurture this like drive to see beyond
what we've already seen yeah great
question thank you I think that it's
just human nature to not want to accept
new beliefs their religious wars on
earth all the time certain people
believe that their religion is right now
this believe that there's and there's no
way to convince them science at least
allows us to determine something
although not all science is good not all
science is pure truth but to the second
part of your question how do we nurture
such people that's that's really the
heart of it I think the society needs
more fucose in Galileo's and Einsteins
Einstein was the quintessential example
of a nonconformist he could watch a
train go by and listen to a bell on a
church bell ring and see the relativity
of things which nobody could see even
today it's very hard to accept
relativity as you move faster your time
slows down
whoo it's so counterintuitive even
though relativity is now 100 years old
it's still very counter intuitive to us
or that time slows around the black hole
black holes were discovered by
Einstein's genius - how could somebody
like Einstein ignore what everybody else
was saying and in fact that ties back to
the first part of your question Joann
where Einstein actually was called a
lazy dog by a famous mathematician who
was his professor at the eth which
the Swiss Polytechnic University in
Zurich he was a student of his name a
person that you have minkovski Hermann
Minkowski Anais and didn't like to show
up to class well people who do these
things drop out of med school or don't
show up to class or whatever Galileo did
they do thinks there are different from
the rest of us and said didn't show up
to class and it wasn't even that he
derived the whole course and sometimes
you have a very smart student I know
that some years of teaching who uh it
was so smart to could sit home and
derive the entire course I son didn't do
that he really was lazy he didn't care
for the mathematics of Mycoskie was
teaching he was interested in his own
things and Minkowski chided him you lazy
dog you don't show up in class years
later minkovski supplied Einstein with a
some of the mathematics that explains
relativity today so the stories about
genius and how genius is different and
how genius fights the rest of society
and conventional wisdoms I think is is a
very interesting one that that is worth
exploring further yes
the first microscope the Dutchman that
developed the first look it was the same
thing he was a great knee made grapes
and it was a janitor
and he was the first one to look at
microorganisms but the Royal Society
totally ignored him right there's so
many cases like that Oh Harrison with
longitude and many I think I think it
maybe even is more the case than the
exception where people
oh I that brings me back to Foucault
again Foucault invented the gyroscope
and the jaw he was looking for a second
proof of the rotation of the earth so
people people were still looking at his
pendulums as proof of the rotation of
the earth and he said wait a minute I
can again move ahead faster than new
people and I can give you a second proof
so a gyroscope which is something he
invented it has an element that's
rotating very fast and because of this
rotation well we've seen toys like that
you can't really it's hard to move them
from their direction because of inertia
so when you create something like that
you give it the the speed to go around
and if you keep feeding it it will stay
in a certain direction if you aim it
that the starch will track the star so
telescopes today with a battery and the
little motor do that by following the
star so you can keep it in one star
without the rotation of the earth
shifting it out of focus well out of the
field of view what he did is he then
realized if he pointed that the North
Star which doesn't rotate around or
that's not really the North Star the
true north which is very close to what
we call
Polaris the North Star nor so I was very
closely but not quite at that point if
you aim it in that direction the
gyroscope will always show you the
direction north now as you may know the
compass the magnetic compass was
replaced by the gyroscope today we have
even better gyroscopes that work with
laser light and interference but until a
few years ago the electric gyroscope
which is just a spinning element
attached to something that with the dial
on it
was what navigators used to show them
there their directions now you'd think
that the theatrical lighting that
invented the gyroscope and other things
that I invented would result in
recognition none of that brought him
recognition and the gyroscope remained
as pretty much a discarded invention
until later in the 1800s
I think it's around 1896 a an Austrian
engineer decided who was interested in
warfare said hmm there's something
called the gyroscope what would happen
if I put it inside the torpedo it will
direct the torpedo to the enemy because
torpedoes are very inaccurate until that
point so a lot of people lost their
lives because of that and and soon
afterwards shipping companies used it on
ships so Foucault should have become
very wealthy just for such an invention
navigation think of the internet or
something like that if you can allow
people to to have a compass that defined
directions that are accurate so they
don't have to use a magnetic compass
that is really given to a lot of
disturbances that's an invention that's
worth a lot of money they never made a
penny on that so being unappreciated
tends to be if not I don't know if it's
the exception or the rule but it happens
a lot yes
also is in non-catholic countries of
Europe was
theories level West Campus isn't that
different in other countries and in
other parts of the world there was less
of well my best understanding of the
essence of your question comes from
letters of the cart that I've read the
cart left France to this was you know
earlier 200 years earlier to live in
Holland because Holland had less of a
persecution of people who believed in
the rotation of the earth so even within
Europe there are variations in how badly
people were persecuted it really
dependent on how important the church
was in the particular country in Italy
the story Galileo gives a good example
to even an Italy itself Galileo was very
safe while he was in the Venetian
Republic because the Venetians didn't
care much for the Roman Catholic Church
and they did whatever they wanted they
were the power for a thousand years as
we know and Galileo was invited to stay
there he was at the University of Padua
which is in the Venna towards its close
to Venice the city of Venice and he was
very safe there but he galileo really
liked to taunt the church in his
writings very very overtly calling the
views of the church simply the views of
simple issues he had the dialogue
dialogues and simply meet for for a
simpleton the simpleton was a church and
the smart guy was Galileo he liked to
taunt them at one point he decided I'm
moving back to Florence I don't care if
I'm safer here he moved back to his
native Florence where he thought the
Archduke would protect him but the
Archduke's powers were not as strong as
those of the church and eventually was
forced to come to Rome and stand trial
and trough the Inquisition so to answer
your question and even in Europe itself
there are safer places and more
dangerous places for free thinkers and
for science outside of Europe we don't
really know
there aren't really letters of people
who were worried and moved from one
country to the next to tell us that they
were persecuted I suspect people is much
safer here and probably in Asia than in
Europe but science was done a lot in
Europe so even though the dangers were
greater there that was a place there was
the center of science so science along
with other human endeavors kept moving
west through history starting with well
starting in Babylonia Babylonian
astronomy and mathematics was very very
advanced there actually you can see clay
tablets describing the motion of Venus
going back to early centuries BC then it
moved to Athens Greece and then Berlin
was an important center of Science and
Mathematics in earlier part of the 1800s
and then Paris became a very important
Center and I think everything is
centered in the United States today so
there's this direction West
any other questions you don't want me to
prove the sign law there's an
interesting proof of the sign law I have
two appendices in my book with proofs of
the sign law and as soon as Foucault I
should mention did not prove this sign
law so he was a genius but not being
trained as a mathematician he could
intuitively derive the law but he
couldn't prove it mathematically we know
the law is correct and it could have
been proven just statistically because
many observations were made at different
latitudes
however mathematicians once they became
accustomed to Foucault and the fact that
they had to accept them came up with
proofs of Foucault sign law and today I
haven't counted them but there are many
many proofs of Foucault sine law some
are more interesting someone's simpler
some are harder there none of them are
trivial there these are complicated
proofs but if you're interested in the
proof of that and then I hope you are in
my second appendix in the book of the
second part of the appendix there's a
very interesting proof which looks at
the rotation of this disc on the floor
in the pantheon how that rotates so you
think of the of the pendulum here how
fast is the northern part of the circle
of sand is what they call it was a
circle of the big circle of sand and the
floor of the pantone how fast is it
moving in absolute terms as compared to
the southern part and the difference
between these two speeds eventually with
some mathematical derivation gives you a
Foucault sine law so if you like
mathematical proofs I think of all the
proofs I've seen that's a very beautiful
one because it uses simple trigonometry
some imagination and and the great idea
that the earth is moving the northern
part of the circle of sand moves slower
than the southern one why slower the
same thing with the cannon cannon ball
would be deviating to the east or the
merry-go-round so where you're further
down from the North Pole you are farther
away in the swing and therefore you move
faster so the lower this
southern lip of this circle of sand
moves faster than the northerner when
you do a little computation and the
difference between the two some terms
fall out and you get the sine love it
and in the most elegant way I like
mathematics in the most elegant way that
I've seen yes a gyroscope one that
simply doesn't reverse course but yeah
good question no he didn't think of it
as a pendulum at all he knew this is
something that again Foucault never
ceases to amaze us maleeh when we're
told he was not trained he didn't he had
a an amazing intuition about physics and
mathematics he understood this idea of
inertia the pendulum has inertia it's
moving back and forth like so and so
does something that's spinning but
they're very different this kind of
spinning disk or a top or whatever has
inertia in this way it's it's something
that doesn't want to stop it wants to
continue spinning this is not the same
as a pendulum that's doing this so
that's why it wasn't a pendulum the
getting the idea for the disk it was the
understanding of the principle of why
the pendulum stays its course and why
something spinning would keep its
direction it was the idea rather than a
similarity between the two because
they're very different today in modern
physics people talk about what would
happen to a pendulum up in space what
what would it follow and if you get into
relativity there's something called
frame dragging and other effects they're
studied with gyroscopes or the idea of a
pendulum they're used equivalently of
course when actually they do the actual
science they use modern gyroscopes that
are very accurate with laser light and
so on but in in physics textbooks you'll
read something like what would happen to
a Foucault pendulum in a particular
location in space or another place it
would say what would happen to a to a
gyroscope
in Earth orbit or something like that so
the idea is the same but there but what
they do is different one rotates the
other one just goes back and forth
amir axel is author of fair Ma's Last
Theorem God's equation and the riddle of
the compass
his latest pendulum is published by
atria books an imprint of Simon and
Schuster visit Simon Says dot-com for
more information next week on